the power Cuts began 16 years ago aging
and poorly maintained power plants
state-owned power utilities short of
funding and Corruption have made them
worse outages can last anywhere between
6 and 12 hours a day
some areas are often without electricity
for days economists say the blackouts
are costing the country thousands of
jobs and damaging its economy the
government and state utility company
call that load shedding and it's
angering much of the country
that we took a stand as the people of
this country against this corrupt
government that we have and fight for
what we have as rights in this country
it's time for us to stand together
some businesses are suing the government
for their losses the poultry Industries
had to call 10 million chicks as
shortages of electricity have delayed
production and agricultural producers
have asked for exemptions from the
blackouts with many concerned Food
Supplies will be reduced
the national energy regulator says the
cost of electricity will go up by almost
20 percent later this year
six would argue protests like this one
won't end the rolling blackouts the
power utility escom says they will
continue for at least another two years
despite that people here are hoping
their frustration is heard before it's
too late and the economy and country are
crippled Al Jazeera Johannesburg